Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at why July
4th was ultimately chosen as Independence
Day in the United States.
While it is often said that the Declaration
of Independence was signed on July 4, 1776,
this isn't actually correct.
In fact, nobody signed it on the 4th.
This is contradictory to Thomas Jefferson’s,
John Adams’, and Benjamin Franklin’s account
of events.
On top of their accounts, the public congressional
record of events back their story.
So how do we know it didn't happen this way?
To begin with, the Secret Journals of Congress
that were eventually made public in 1821 paint
a different story.
They contain an entry stating, on August 2nd:
“The declaration of independence being engrossed
& compared at the table was signed by the
Members.”
Now if this was the only evidence, one might
lean towards a typo in the journal and believing
the aforementioned three individuals and public
congressional record.
However, one of the other signers of the declaration,
Thomas McKean, denied the July 4th signing
date and backed it up by illustrating a glaring
flaw in Jefferson’s, Adams’, and Franklin’s
argument- namely, that most of the signers
were not members of congress on July 4th and
thus wouldn’t have been there to sign it.
As McKean said in 1796: “No person signed
it on that day nor for many days after."
Further evidence comes from the interesting
fact that the parchment version of the Declaration
of Independence that is on display and kept
in the United States National Archives wasn’t
actually written until July 19th; this being
a copy of the approved text that was announced
to the world on July 4th, with about 150-200
copies being made on paper and distributed
on that date (26 of which are still around
today, thus pre-dating what is now generally
thought of by most as the “original”).
This little tidbit also came from the Secret
Journals of Congress which has an entry on
July 19th stating: “Resolved that the Declaration
passed on the 4th be fairly engrossed on parchment
with the title and stile of 'The unanimous
declaration of the thirteen united states
of America' & that the same when engrossed
be signed by every member of Congress.”
So, in the end, this signed document probably
would have been copied by Timothy Matlack,
Jefferson’s clerk, rather than penned by
Jefferson himself, and certainly couldn’t
have been signed on July 4th.
It's also interesting to note that John Adams
thought that July 2nd, not July 4th, would
be ultimately celebrated in the United States
as Independence Day.
On July 3, 1776, in a letter to his wife,
Abigail, Adams noted:
"The second day of July, 1776, will be the
most memorable epoch in the history of America.
I am apt to believe that it will be celebrated
by succeeding generations as the great anniversary
festival.
It ought to be commemorated as the day of
deliverance, by solemn acts of devotion to
God Almighty.
It ought to be solemnized with pomp and parade,
with shows, games, sports, guns, bells, bonfires,
and illuminations, from one end of this continent
to the other, from this time forward forever
more."
So why did he think July 2nd would be Independence
Day and how did July 4th end up getting the
nod instead?
Because July 2nd is when the Second Continental
Congress voted to approved a resolution of
independence.
Although nobody voted on or signed the Declaration
of Independence on July 4th, that was the
date the Declaration was announced to the
world, and why it was ultimately chosen as
Independence Day.
So thanks for watching this video, if you
liked it, please click that like button below
and consider sharing it with anyone you think
might be interested . And of course if you’re
new to TodayIFoundOut, don’t forget to click
the subscribe button to get more interesting
videos like this.
We release a new video almost every single
day, so you’re sure to find something you
find interesting.
Thanks for watching.